Salut !
C'est parti pour le deuxième jour sur
la méthode pour résoudre un Rubik's Cube en moins de deux minutes !
Et avec maximum 5 formules
Et surtout vous vous demandez pourquoi comme fond de décor
j'ai un sanglier et des potions...
Alors non, j'ai pas refait la déco de chez moi,
c'est que je tourne cette série de vidéos au Youtube Space à Paris
et qu'en ce moment y'a les décors de Game of Thrones
Je trouvais que ça allait bien dans le décor
Hier, quand on s'est quitté
vous aviez appris à faire la première face
et la première couronne d'un Rubik's Cube
j'y ai pas touché depuis
déjà parce que pour moi c'était pas hier
c'était il y a 10 minutes *rires*
Et aujourd'hui,
on va s'attaquer un petit peu aux formules
pour résoudre la deuxième couronne
Y'a quelque chose que je vous ai pas encore dit
sur le Rubik's Cube
c'est que, dans le langage
des gens qui font du Rubik's Cube,
on identifie un sens de rotation
Le sens normal de rotation
c'est le sens horaire
et, quand on tourne à l'inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
on dit qu'on tourne en sens inverse
Si je prend la face,
ce qui est à vous en ce moment là
cette face là
si je la tourne normalement
je la tourne dans ce sens là,
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
Par contre, si je la tourne dans ce sens là,
c'est que je la tourne en sens inverse
Et là vous vous dites "D'accord,
mais comment tu fais pour la face du dessus,
la face supérieure ?"
Et bah de la même manière,
ça c'est le sens horaire
et ça c'est le sens inverse
et cette face là, comment je fais ?
et bah ça c'est le sens horaire
et ça c'est le sens inverse
Pour déterminer le sens horaire
c'est très simple,
il faut que vous vous imaginiez toujours
en face du cube
que vous allez tourner
parce que là, on a l'impression que je vais à l'inverse
alors que je vais dans le bon sens,
dans le sens horaire
si je place la face devant nous,
on voit que c'était le bon sens horaire
et ça le sens inverse
Petit test de compréhension
Là, pour remettre ça ici, en place,
cette face, elle va tourner
dans le sens normal ou dans le sens inverse ?
Elle a tourné dans le sens inverse
Oui, c'est pas très compliqué !
mais je sais que c'est beaucoup d'informations
à retenir d'un coup
c'est pour ça que je vous l'ai pas expliqué hier
Par contre, hier, je vous ai dit
qu'il y avait 6 endroits qui ne bougeaient pas,
qui étaient fixes
puisque c'est l'axe fixe du Rubik's Cube
tel que monsieur Rubik l'a construit en 74
ce sont toutes les faces centrales
celle-ci, celle-ci, celle-ci, celle-ci
celle-ci et celle ci
On va maintenant les positionner en fonction
de notre première couronne
c'est à dire que si il y a du orange ici,
faut que toute cette face là soit orange
et comme les cubes centraux sont fixes,
ici il faut que se soit absolument le cube orange.
ici il faudrait que ce soit le cube vert, là le cube rouge et ici le cube bleu !
Et je peux vous dire que c'est pas le plus compliqué que vous allez apprendre
Puisqu'il suffit de tourner l'ensemble de ces deux blocs
Jusqu'à temps que ça corresponde pour votre face visible
Là c'est bon.
On a le bleu sur le bleu donc, automatiquement, on a le rouge sur le rouge, le vert sur le vert et le orange sur le orange.
C'était tout l'intérêt de créer au départ la première couronne.
Juste en tournant l'ensemble, vous en avez placez 4 sur les 12. C'est quand même pas mal !
Il en reste plus que 8 à placer.
La seule couleur qui nous intéresse pas pour le moment c'est la couleur jaune puisque la couleur jaune se sera celui du dessus du cube qu'on est en train de faire.
Parce que maintenant qu'on a réalisé la première face et la première couronne,
la première face on va la laisser en dessous tout le temps
on a plus besoin d'y revenir.
Vous vous rendez compte que vous en avez placé déjà 4 sur les 8 !
Vous avez fait 50% du chemin juste en tournant un petit peu le rubik's cube.
Il nous reste 4 cubes à placer maintenant. Ce sont les 4 qui couvrent 2 faces en même temps.
Pour faire ça on va utiliser une identification et deux formules possibles en fonction, si on veut aller à droite ou à gauche.
Et 2 formules possibles qui se ressemblent vraiment !
La 1ère chose que vous devez faire
C'est placer au dessus d'un des cubes centraux un cube de la même couleur
comme c'est le cas ici spontanément
Mais on aurait pu en chercher un bleu
ou un vert
Etape 1
Au dessus d'un des centraux, en placer un de la même couleur
Et c'est celui qui va chercher à déplacer
on va chercher à le déplacer sur la face où il y a la 2ème couleur donc la face orange qui est ici
ce qu'on souhaite faire c'est déplacer celui ci
ici
donc de l'emmener sur la gauche
pour l'emmener sur la gauche, il y a une formule
Et qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit cette formule. Elle nous dit:
Haut gauche inversé
haut gauche, haut avant
haut avant inversé
alors je vous écris la formule juste en dessous et je vous propose une méthode d'écriture
quand je met un / devant une lettre ça veut dire inversé
et si je met une parenthèse, ça veut dire que toutes les lettres à l'intérieur sont inversées
donc on voit
on inverse haut, on inverse gauche
on fait haut, on fait gauche
on fait haut, on fait avant
on inverse haut, on inverse avant
Vous allez voir que dans les doigts, en plus, c'est assez facile à faire
Donc on a dit que pour placer celui ci, ici.
Il fallait commencer par faire
Haut inversé
donc haut inversé
Je tourne mon haut dans ce sens là
parce que si je regarde bien de face, je tourne bien dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
Gauche inversée, donc la gauche c'est cette arête là
inversée donc dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
haut gauche inversé c'est fait.
Ensuite haut normal
et gauche normal
on vient d'appliquer, déjà, la moitié de la formule
et ce qu'on va vouloir faire, c'est isoler ces 2 là, pour venir les charger ensuite dessus
Donc la suite de la formule c'était haut avant
donc
Haut dans le bon sens
Avant dans le bon sens
puis haut inversé,
et avant inversé
Et là, on avait bien notre 1ère couronne qui était alignée
le centre, que l'on a placé au début de cette vidéo
sans casser, évidemment, ni la face blanche, ni la 1ère couronne
mais qu'est ce qui ce serait passé s'il avait fallu placer celui ci
à droite
Ben comme c'est le cas pour lui d'ailleurs
Bleu/Rouge, ce Bleu/Rouge va là
Et bien on a une autre formule
qui ressemble, par contre, à la 1ère formule c'est pour ça qu'elles sont faciles à retenir
Elle est facile à retenir parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il y avait gauche vous direz droite
donc quand on va de ce côté là, évidemment, on pense à la gauche. Quand on va de ce côté là on pense à la droite
et la grande différence par rapport à l'autre formule
c'est que tout ce qui était inversé ne l'est plus
et tout ce qui était dans le sens normal est maintenant inversé
ce qui donne donc:
Haut droite
haut droite inversé, haut avant inversé
haut avant
ce sont vraiment 2 formules frangines
et encore je les identifie comme 2 formules
mais on pourrait dire que c'est qu'une seule formule
mais bon, j'assume et je les intègre dans le fait de vous avoir promis de retenir que 5 formules
J'ai mon bleu/rouge ici et je veux l'emmener là
donc on a dit
Haut dans le bon sens
droite dans le bon sens
haut inversé
droite inversée
Haut inversé
avant inversé
haut dans le bon sens
et avant dans le bon sens
et en même temps on vient de finir tous les bleus
sans casser les blancs
et en respectant, tous ce qui a été fait précédemment sur la 1ère et 2ème couronne
on va terminer d'ailleurs cette 2ème couronne
ici on a du vert/orange donc je vais le mettre
le vert sur le vert
comme on a vu
ça va à droite
donc haut dans le bon sens, droite dans le bon sens
haut inversé, droite inversée
haut inversé, face inversée
haut dans le bon sens, face dans le bon sens
et on vient de finir le vert
le orange s'est mis en place,
le bleu aussi
le rouge, il nous manque que le rouge
et là, problème le rouge est là
ben non, c'est pas un problème. On va se positionner du coup sur le vert
Et il faut qu'on emmène ce cube la,
Ici
donc on va reprendre la 1ère formule qui été celle sur la gauche avec
Haut inversé
gauche inversée
haut dans le bon sens
gauche dans le bon sens
avant dans le bon sens
haut inversé
avant inversé
et on vient de finir cette deuxième couronne
DIS DONC on irait pas super vite
on vient de finir la 2ème couronne
Donc vous avez vu les 4 du centre étaient très facile à placer
et pour placer les 4 qui sont à cheval il suffit de retenir 2 formules
qui sont assez voisines quand on retient l'une, on retient l'autre assez facilement
Je vous propose donc de vous entraînez maintenant
à faire la 2ème couronne
en plus de les retenir dans votre tête, vous allez comprendre toute la logique
de sens avant, sens arrière
et vous allez commencer à retenir ça dans les doigts
c'est à dire qu'après vous allez même plus réciter la formule ça va se faire tout seul
Ne perdez surtout pas votre motivation demain on apprend la formule la plus simple
C'est une formule à 3 mouvements
Entraînez-vous bien
Amusez-vous bien.
Dans la découverte de la résolution du Rubik's cube
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog
Ciao!